all right thank you for this
introduction hopefully all of you will
understand more about what I'm
presenting about here um when I walked
up the stairs here I know that there's
this quote from Albert Einstein saying
logic will get you from point A to B but
imagination will get you everywhere
um I started thinking about it because I
don't know if this holds for fussy logic
as well which will be part of my
discussion today who view is familiar
with fuzzy logic
okay if I ask this question again in 30
minutes from now hopefully more people
will raise the hand that's part of my uh
my talk not the main focus yeah so we uh
I will present the package for topic
modeling using fuzzy logic fuzzy
clustering
um so my name is Emil Greg I'm doing my
PhD at Intel University of Technology
and then positioned in them both at the
euronymous Academy of data science also
called yachts
the
yesterday the
foreign
although the name almost resembles
kovitz it doesn't have to do anything
with it it stands for computing visits
data uh yeah just the name of the
project
it's a collaboration between einsof
um Universal Utrecht and the lighter
University Medical Center we work in
mental Healthcare and a natural language
processing in mental health care
uh so yeah again I will present first
ctm a python package for state of the
Arts fussy topic modeling a few
big statements uh the first in the world
for for fussy topic modeling we also
have user-friendly pipelines and in
meantime also modular design allows for
other algorithms to be added uh I'll
discuss this further during the talk
um
yeah so they understand better why
um so is everyone here familiar with
topic modeling
okay that's good for the people that
aren't I still will introduce it a
little bit the the official definition I
think or the one I often use in my
papers is that it's a unsupervised
natural language processing algorithm
that extract latent topics in texts and
there are many different algorithms out
there for fuzzy topic modeling but what
most of them have in common is that you
inputs a corpus which is a document of
or a set of documents of uh with text
they need to set the number of topics
that you want to find in your algorithm
and then typically the algorithm
returns to matrices one is the
probability of a words given a topic and
the second one is the probability of a
topic given the documents and then for
the yeah the way most people use this
algorithm is that from the first Matrix
they take the top n words per topic and
those if the algorithms work the way we
want them to work follow some kind of
theme or or topic
um so here's a example
uh
oh wait yes sorry so we we have this
Matrix uh suppose we train our Corpus on
um a data sets with uh with lyrics
and we want to find three topics
here you see three topics in 10 words
per topic
um Can anyone see which lyrics this is
about
so this is the idea of topic modeling
the Hue uh
get works and then if they follow some
kind of distribution you recognize
themes in them
and then you can use those topic models
uh
either just to analyze documents but you
can also use it as to create embeddings
of other documents and use this inputs
for text classification there was
actually the motivation why we started
working with with topic modeling
so probably most people that know topic
modeling know LDA late interior collect
allocation
however there are many different
algorithms out there uh
yeah so Brad LDA is also one of the
newer ones works with with neural
networks and LDA uh LSA
um it's an older one latent semantic
analysis it's uh I think it produces or
it
performs singular value decomposition on
documentary Matrix
and then returns to the u and v Matrix
as as both matrices that I just
mentioned
um so if there are so many algorithms
out there why should we care about fussy
topic modeling
um and since I saw a little hints in the
beginning what does fussy mean what is
fuzzy logic uh to illustrate the idea of
fussy logic if the following a picture
here and who thinks this is a black dog
who thinks it's a brown dog
okay I see some hands but there's some
doubts this directly illustrates the
idea of fuzzy logic namely that in this
case a dock can be can have a membership
to certain sets here it has some
membership to the set of black docks and
some membership to the set of brown
ducks
um and that's the opposite to to crisp
logic uh where yeah you have to just
have one definite set but for this
reason I think uh if you have fussy
logic it won't just bring you from point
A to point B but maybe partly membership
to to point C or or B whatever
um
to illustrate this further you have a
line in your membership here you see the
membership degree to set of black docks
um well the the white dock the white
puppy and the the bottom left doesn't
have any memberships to this set
and the blacker the duck Ducks gets the
higher their their membership
um you can use this this logic to
model various phenomena
um
yeah so if you compare probabilities
with uh with fussiness probability is
the relatedness to Randomness and
uncertainty described by the tendency or
frequency of a random variable to take
on a value in a specific region
and fuzzy sets are related to
gradualness
I think you all already have a
yeah intuition of what it is but the
next example we'll even clarify this
more
clearly so please I'll close your eyes
and imagine yourself walking into in the
deserts
and unfortunately you've lost your water
it's really hot deserts
um
you're thirsty and all you can see is
his deserts and incense
um and if they're having best so many
sand dunes you hope to see something
else in the desert only so now you're
walking over the next 10 June
and the first thing you see is this you
can open your eyes now
you become really happy
but the reason why you're so happy is
not because you see her no there's
there's water
so there are two bottles
um you're really thirsty so you want to
drink uh and then you see the labels on
those bottles
and one says there's poison in this uh
or the membership to poison of the first
bottle is 0.10
and the other one says the probability
of poison is point one also Point ten
um now you're thinking like what's what
which bottle should I drink
you know if you can safely drink water
with the membership of poison of uh or
15. so the the membership of 10 is lower
than 15 so you can still safely drink it
however the one with the probability of
0.10
it gives you 10 chance that the poison
is so high if you can't drink it anymore
uh
yeah that's the clear intuition of what
fuzzy logic does an aim of memberships
mean and how they compare to
probabilities
which bottle will go for the membership
what is it I think everyone will get
slam into
um okay so that's fancy logic and why
then should we care about fussy topic
modeling
um yeah so our reasoning is a
probability probabilistic topic models
estimate the probability of um finding
in words
in a topic however we think it's more
intuitive to think that uh words belong
to topics with some kind of membership
um and hence we yeah we started working
with fussy topic modeling
um so what is it last year we proposed a
new algorithm it was already an
algorithm called fussy latent semantic
analysis which is based on LSA
and then we proposed a alternative to it
we called it flsa w which ends for f
let's say words
um
and we found really good results so this
the idea of the pipeline of the
algorithm you start with your Corpus
then for your Corpus you create a
document term Matrix so it has all the
different vocabulary words as rows in
the each document is a column it just
counts the appearance of words in
documents
um then based on this Matrix you
calculate Global term which which could
be TF IDF which I think most of you will
be familiar with but you can also choose
entropy for example
it goes too fast based on global term
which you uh using your value
decomposition for dimensionality
reduction
so actually until now this is LSA
but then with flsa and fsaw we go
further we take the I always confuse if
the U Matrix or the V Matrix but one of
the Matrix is from singular value
decomposition with the characteristic
that it has the number of words by the
number of singular values we clustering
the space
and then using base theorem and Matrix
multiplications we we find the right
matrices that will return to the yeah
the outputs as all algorithms do
um if you want to see how we did it
there's a reference to the paper
so we ran results to see how our
algorithm compares to other algorithms
so what you see on the left is
a few of the algorithms we built
compared to other algorithms we also
tried a different approach which we got
FSA V uh it's harder to run and it
didn't perform as well so here I focus
only on FSA w
ow uh I think we ran it under yeah the
M10 data set we've read it on various
open data sets so it can be uh verified
um in each column you see the number of
topics so what we did for each number of
topics we ran each algorithm 10 times
and then we reported the average
performance metrics
often topic models are evaluated using
the coherence score which indicates how
well words within a topic support each
other and would support each other we
mean how often they they co-occur in
inner Corpus
um but let's only focuses on the quality
within the topic and this is a little
bit limited because if you have one
topic with words that all support each
other then the coherence would still be
high if you had three identical topics
which doesn't make sense so much we
think so there there's also the
diversity score and that looks at how
different topics relate to each other if
they are all unique or or to what extent
to a membership now they uh
um
have similar words or or different words
and then interpretability score is just
the product of the the coherence score
and the diversity
uh yeah here I'm just proudly showing
our results uh compared to other
algorithms
um if you want we ran this on various
data sets also dblp BBC News and
20 News Group this link shows you
all the experimental results
um yeah so that's another motivation for
using fussy topic models
uh also recently we've developed fsae we
try to fill all the letters in the
alphabet so we send it to a few letters
to go
this one stands for FSA embedding so
here we train a word to vac embedding
cluster then in this embedding space and
perform multi Matrix multiplications to
also find the right output matrices
uh also this work has been published I
presented it a few months ago in in
Prague
um the coherent score of this model is
good however the diversity is pretty low
so we still
need to look into this further to see
how we can make it work better because
we suspected this in the end will be a
better approach
it is featured in in fast etm
uh yeah so
we have four different algorithms
featured currently in fast etm the
original algorithm FSA then FSA W flsav
and fsae
uh currently we have a new idea we check
our fsac but it's not featured here yet
and that's uh not published
um as you can see the algorithms all go
through a similar set of steps to uh to
find the output matrices and that's also
our explore like how
um the package works
so here you see one mother class uh fast
ctm and then for each algorithm there's
a child class
I don't think even people in the first
row can see uh what is this
uh so here yeah these are the most
important methods in the uh in the
package so when you run an algorithm you
just initialize it as FSA or flaw
um you need to uh give your Corpus in a
number of topics and then when your
model is initialized you just run the
method get made with this and it then
connects to the mother class goes
through the steps as indicated in the
algorithm and then Returns the uh the
output matrices
um so few since we had Pi Data Insights
into the code itself
um when you run this algorithm you need
to input a list of list of strings or
tokens
and we have a hard check in the
beginning to make sure that this is the
right data that he inputs so no issues
occur later on
um
oh yeah so since in the beginning of the
algorithm we work with a documentary
Matrix which is the number of
the vocabulary size by the number of
documents your data sets could be or
data frame could become really big
for example we worked with the hospital
data and we had 90 000 unique words and
four maybe four and a half thousand
documents uh so that's I think a space
of like 300 million cells uh and that's
that's yeah you can't really handle that
so therefore we use uh sparse matrices
in this case the the doc Matrix which is
a dictionary of geese uh
you can use it with sci-fi I believe
um yeah you can still use arithmetic
operations with it and it's just an
efficient way of handling your sparse
data
um yeah we use spy film for fuzzy
clustering it's produced by one of my
other uh or like beer peer phds
um and my same promoter uh but it's if
you want to use clustering um
it features fcm which is an alternative
to
k-means clustering it's just a fuzzy
alternative
um
so if you want to use fuzzy cloud or
clustering in general I also recommend
using this python package to see what
your results will be like
also the paper is published at IEEE for
that we believe
um yeah so another method in our python
package is the get topic embedding so
you can use topic modeling to analyze
text on its own we can also use it to
embed your your documents for other
Downstream tasks
so with the methods get topic embedding
you can input new documents and then
it's if it calculates the extent to
which different topics appear in your
new documents and then you can use those
matrices as input embeddings
there are different settings here that
you can play with
and we haven't experimented with with
the results of of or or what what the
best methods are so you can set the top
n words that you want to use to
represent your topic
but also
um percentile of top words if you want
to include
and then it just looks in the text to to
find uh these words and and calculates
uh
the percentage I guess
um to the extent of which they appear
um yeah so there's also just this safe
in the loads method if you have trained
your your firstly topic model since the
juice is fuzzy clustering which is
randomly initialized in the beginning
and you want it it will return it's not
deterministic so it will always return
different results
uh so therefore the safe and load method
will help you to save your method and
and work on it later on we use pickle2
to save models
oh yeah so in the beginning one of the
claims I made about fuzzy TM is that it
is user friendly Pipelines
um and it can be ran with three lines of
codes
looking at this code you might be
counting and be like hey there are more
than three lines
but those are the only lines needed to
to train it so you
uh yeah in the beginning we just used
the octis data as an example M10 for
which I also showed the experimental
results
so after you have installed First ATM
you import FSA w
then you initialize your model uh saying
fsaw and then use your data and set
number of topics
um and then you just run it to to get
your output matrices so you get your
your first one the probability of a word
given a topic and the probability of a
topic given the documents
um
and then once your model has trained
which is
pretty fast compared to other algorithms
you can see your topics using the FSA
showed topics methods if you use
representations works you'll see the
words only if you use representation as
both then you will see both the
probabilities or the memberships
um in the words
uh to get the scores the performance
course you just use get to go here and
score get diversity score or get
interpretability score
for coherence typically needs to
uh work a little bit or think a little
bit to to write science code to order
the red score just because it's uh
looks at the Corpus and the
co-occurrence of the words in your topic
so this will be the output of our uh our
model uh coherent score of 0.53 which is
relatively High compared to other
algorithms uh height or yeah diversity
score an interpretability score
um so the dependencies of the ctm are
numpy Benda sci-fi and Pi fume this used
to be sparse SVD as well but there were
some troubles due to uh installing so we
got it out
um
yeah just a short wrap up of what what I
discussed so we've developed the first
python package uh for for fancy topic
modeling uh our algorithms outperform
other states of the art algorithms a
model can be trained with minimal
efforts and users can plug in their own
methods to quickly go back and give an
example so I told you that I'm now
working with fsa's c
uh we got this idea last Monday
um wait
so I discussed last Monday with my
promoter oh maybe we can do this and
this step to uh to get new output
matrices and then it only took me 20
minutes to implement it using the the
package just because all the modules are
there already which was nice
um
okay yeah so right now we're also
working on an extension for fussy TM for
topic analysis so typically only the
coherence score and diversity are used
to evaluate a topic uh however I find
this weird because it's it's a high it's
a set of sets a set of sets
um
it's like you you try to summarize all
these multi-dimensional data with with
one value or two values only
um so in this extension we
yep we'll use different methods to uh
analyze your topic but more like a
descriptive statistics of your your
topic models to understand them better
um yeah also we've pushed uh a
repository to to gen Sim so there will
be an implementation there as well like
Dave suppose you're all familiar with
Gen Sim since you know new topic
modeling
um and if anyone has ideas for other
algorithms it's work in some kind of
similar Pipeline and please push it to
repast story we will look at it and uh
this way we can extend the package as
well
um here my contact details so you can
find FIFA ctm on my GitHub also every
now and then I write blocks uh about
topic modeling but also other subjects
related to
um
yeah to NLP or or data science which you
can find on my medium accounts email
Geiger
uh this is the Intimate Presentation I
can see how much time is left but
thank you are there any questions
several questions uh ladies first
so the question is the only thing that
you provide is the Corpus and yes that's
correct
applications that
okay so I'm repeating all the questions
so it's recorded so uh if I can mention
some applications using topic modeling
um yeah so for for example uh what we
used it for as well one of our students
worked with feedback data in the
hospital so people that have gone had a
surgery at the hospital then later they
were asked how uh how what they liked
about their their help and what they
didn't like
um or didn't care
and this is a lot like a big data set so
it's many written comments and it's hard
to analyze it using topic models we find
the topics that many people focus on in
this way it can be used to analyze it so
it's often used for
yeah seeing
um
what kind of support or what kind of
feedback is is given what people talk
about if you have large data sets
so and the motivation for us to to use
topic modeling is to make deck
classification more interpretable so
typically when you work with text
classification you you have your input
embedding like Burt embedding or where
to vek you feed this into your algorithm
it can be any kind of classification
algorithm and a if your output data
um but then even if your model works
well it's hard to see how your your
classification algorithm makes its
decisions just because the the high
dimensionality of your your words
embeddings
the idea with topic model topic modeling
is it's for each input Dimension you
know what it stands for because it's
some kind of topic and then if if you're
if you feed that to your classification
algorithm you see the weights to each
topic and in this way it could make text
classification more uh interpretable
those are two examples okay another
question in the back
finally
good question so the question is how do
you determine the number of topics
beforehand
it could be done with trial and error
some people use the the coherence score
to see to find some kind of optimal
coherence score I'm not a big fan of
this uh but it kind of depends I think
on the the level of
specificity of what topics you want to
see currently I'm also looking at uh
yeah kind of the specificity of words
produced by topic if you for many
algorithms it holds it if you increase
the number of topics they become more
specific
so they contain words that appear less
often in your Corpus than when you use
less topics so it kind of depends on
your
desired uh results but what kind of
context you want to see your topics to
be in to uh to set a number of topics
and it's it's as with many things in
data science I think the answer is also
just go and try and see what uh which
number of topics give the best topics
okay another question
okay
ah okay thank you so the question is
I shouldn't stand in front of this uh if
I can elaborate on the the coherence
score that I use in the diversity score
because there's no such thing
um
because there's several coherence scores
indeed
the this coherence score I mentioned
here is to see fecal here and score
um to see I simply the reason we use it
there's a paper from 2015 by a router
and he Compares many different types of
settings of coherence scores and fines
that the CV correlates most with or
highest with human interpretation
um so so that's what we use here uh
we use the Jensen implementation in the
the package so you can use all kind of
CV scores to uh to get your coherence
score but the defaults will be CV
uh as far as the diversity score I'm not
sure if there are different definitions
[Music]
oh okay uh
yes exactly okay uh oh interesting I
would like to hear more about this well
so the formula for the diversity score
is a number of unique words in all your
topics divided by the total number of
words
um so if each each topic has unique
words then the score will be one but if
different topics share their uh share
some words and score will be lower it's
always a score between uh zero and one
it can be zero but a little bit more
okay
any other question
so the question is
um in fsae we work with uh word to VEC
word embeddings uh but are also now more
state-of-the-art embeddings such as
Birds contextualized models uh it's yeah
to work with and yes I am I'm planning
to work with it as well there are some
some bird models already
uh the topic bird I believe in ctm I
think uh but yeah I I will look into
that as well
okay
any other question
no okay well thanks for your attendance
for being here and enjoy your day here
at padeta